three leftist lunatics and of course
their masked morons at a coffee at a
coffee shop harassing a Jewish customer
who just wants to go to the bathroom
private property want you going to the
restroom I need you to leave I know
Israel loves taking private property and
saying it's their own but we got to head
you're not going to let me go the restom
so I need you to leave I want you to go
into the restroom I need you to leave
you're not going to let me into the
restroom you can use our other restroom
if we have another rest I want to use
this one yeah history didn't start in
1948 lady free Palestine now free
Palestine it's always please thank you
it's always yeah great we love it
they've all been fired so actually
there's a nice ending to this story
these people no longer work at that
coffee shop imagine regardless of
whatever your feelings are happening
about 10,000 miles away across the
Atlantic in the Middle East that you
would stop a woman from going to the
bathroom who buys a cup of coffee at
your store because of whatever your
feelings about that thing are